welcome to the man of recaps this is the
boys season two season one ended on a
cliffhanger as homelander just
discovered he has a son and he's being
raised by his mother billy butcher's
wife becca who turns out is still alive
but we don't find out what happened here
for a bit billy butcher is missing and
has been blamed for madeline stilwell's
death and so the boys are now america's
most wanted huey mm frenchie and kimiko
laying low off the grid things are great
for homelander though his evil plan was
a huge success to give compound b to
terrorists so the government would allow
supes in the military vaught the
superhero mega corporation didn't know
about this plan so the ceo stan edgar
gives homelander a stern talking to but
they are gonna make a ton of money off
it so he's not that mad annie aka
starlight is still with the seven she
helped the boys escape last season but
the only one who knows that is a train
who's still in his heart attack at deuce
coma she's still working secretly to
expose vots corruption and trying to
maintain her long-distance relationship
with yui now they finally admit
translucent is dead so it's time for a
new member of the seven meet stormfront
a young hero from the next generation
who's much better at tock than these old
farts and she's hugely popular with a
cool calling it like it is vibe now soon
the boys discover a super terrorist has
been smuggled into the country they go
to their cia contacts like if we bring
them in can you clear our names and she
would love to take down vot but wait
what's this her head explodes oh man
what new soup was this just exploding
people's heads but now it's finally time
billy butcher's back our boy's fearless
leader the r-rated captain jack sparrow
for some reason homelander didn't kill
him he dropped him off miles away he and
becca made a deal spare billy's life in
exchange for visitation rights of course
this is awful for becca because her
rapist is now hanging around pretending
to be a nice happy family they're not in
the suburbs it's a secure bot compound
she's like yo get homeland or out of
here but it's like we can't control him
and while hillander's a sociopath he
does want to be a good dad because
remember he was raised in a lab that's
why he has such a weird mommy fetish in
fact he regrets now killing madeleine
stilwell but wait what's this she's
alive he's got her hidden away in a
secret sex cabin but nope nope oh it's
the shape-shifting super gross
eventually butcher finds the compound
yes he and becca reunited he's gonna get
her out of here she's like great let me
just grab my son and it's like oh you
wanna take the kid with us that's not
possible vod will never let him go so
she's like well i gotta stay with my son
now butcher goes to their other cia
contact grace mallory the original
founder of the boys they gotta bring in
the super terrorists to clear their
names but turns out kimiko knows this
guy it is her brother yeah remember as
kids they were abducted by this
terrorist group and kimiko was supposed
to be the original super terrorist but
when she didn't now they sent her
brother but he's been indoctrinated he
wants to blow stuff up so kimako's gotta
help the boys capture him sorry bro
it'll be for the best they take him out
to c to make the exchange meanwhile
annie's been doing some blackmailing to
get herself a sample of compound v but
now a-train wakes up and he's got proof
she's a traitor but she's got dirt on
him too knows he killed his girlfriend
popclaw so they're at a stalemate so she
leaks compound v yeah finally they did
it vots going down but there's a
developing situation that could help
them spin things because local law
enforcement found the boys and kimiko's
brother escaped and caused a ruckus so
it's like yo seven go stop this super
villain and no one will care where your
powers came from but there's one last
member of the seven the deep who was
canceled last season after starlight
called him out for sexual assault and
he's getting his punishment been
relegated to a hilarious side comic
relief character who's hit rock bottom
he joins a cult the church of the
collective whose recruitment technique
is offering you a fresca they help him
fix his image so he can get back in the
seven and now's his time to shine cause
the boys are out on the water yes the
deep riding in on a whale boom blocking
their escape but billy butcher is
absolutely insane and crashes into this
thing diabolical the rest of the seven
arrive luckily at starlight who finds
huey first but oh she blasts him cause
homelander's right behind her and he's
like look it's time to prove you're not
a traitor you gotta kill him but he's
distracted when kimiko's brother drops a
train on him these two escape but now
stormfront catches up to him with her
lightning powers boom and stormfront
seems not to care about collateral
damage she kills some civilians on
purpose yeah there's just no good heroes
much like homelander she's also a
psychopath and kills kimiko's brother
and now after stopping a super villain
bots able to spin the compound b thing
and face zero consequences now
stormfront the meme queen is more
popular than ever and homelander doesn't
like being upstaged and now he's got a
new problem when a video surfaces of him
not caring about civilian casualties an
aoc type congresswoman newman is trying
to bring vaught and hollander to justice
and homelanders usual tricks just aren't
working anymore now there's a constant
background fear that at any moment
homelander might finally snap and start
lasering people willy-nilly but he holds
himself back for now he craves the
people's love too much instead he goes
to stormfront who sets him up on the
pwning liberal snowflakes fake news
awfulness and tragically it just works
so well the whole maga crowd just loves
him and pretty soon he in stormfront get
it on superhero style cause a lot of
property damage now back to the boys the
mission continues they got a tip about
an old suit named liberty they find out
that back in the 60s the superhero
liberty killed this woman's brother just
for being black yeah that's awful but
why'd it come up now well turns out
liberty is stormfront who apparently
doesn't age and she's even older than
they know not just a racist but a
literal nazi starlight does some
snooping and finds her secret project an
off the books facility with a bunch of
soups with powers that don't quite work
yes compound v only works well on babies
but they're trying to stabilize it in
adults so they can make a soup out of
anyone they want and working here is a
fire starter soup former member of the
seven lamplighter we finally get the
story when the boys were on official
team they blackmailed lamplader to be
their mole at bot but he didn't like
that and killed mallory's grandchildren
as they're leaving frenchie gets made
and in the scuffle a test subject breaks
out and they are not in a good mood to
survive our team's got to work with
lamplader and as they get to talking he
feels bad he didn't know the kids were
in the house now he's willing to make
things right by testifying against vot
at the upcoming congressional hearing
huey babysits while he goes on a porn
bender but now vaut has captured
starlight so he's gotta convince him to
help him break in and rescue her once
inside though lamp later doesn't help he
decides to just end things luckily that
sets off the alarms which lets starlight
absorb some power and boom blast out of
there but now here to stop her is black
noir another member of the seven who
never talks and his equal parts
hilarious and terrifying but stepping in
to save starlight is queen maeve who
defeats black noir with an almond joy
cause he's allergic to nuts so it's time
for the hearing but without lamplighter
they lost the star witness but butcher
found an even better one vott's old
chief science officer who knows all the
dirty secrets but you intimidated him
into testifying basically by drinking
tea really menacingly so this is it the
heroes can't kill him on live tv unless
you had a soup with head exploding
powers that come out of nowhere and
whoever it is they explode a ton of
heads the hearing is cancelled and after
this attack on congress the government
orders a bunch of the new adult safe
compound v so they can make a ton of new
soups to protect us which plays
perfectly into stormfront's secret plan
she'll just make sure only white
supremacists get the doses now
homelander and stormfront have fallen in
love and it's like hey let me come take
you to meet my son but they get annoyed
with becca here so finally decide to
just take him away so becca escapes and
goes to butcher please help me get my
son back but butcher makes a secret deal
with stan edgar i'll get homelander away
from the kid you can take him back then
me and becca are off the hook meanwhile
on the stormfront front they get help
from an unexpected source it's a train
he just got kicked off the seven for
being too slow now and here to help him
out is his old friend the deep with a
fresca and he finds out the real reason
he was kicked off is because stormfront
is a racist so it's like look we aren't
friends but she's gotta go down so he
helps them leak her nazi photos which
even the mega crowd can't get behind
with stormfront distracted they begin
operation distract homelander to get
becca's son back and butcher has a
change of heart i'm not gonna give him
back to bot but when homelander finds
out bot was planning to take his son
away he is none too pleased but now
stormfront comes back so it's a big old
super girl's fight stormfront's gonna
win but another one joins it's queen
maeve again they tried to recruit her
earlier but she wasn't interested but
now she decided to do the right thing
altogether they're winning so
stormfront's gonna fly out of there she
goes to get the kid back gonna kill
becca butcher let go my mom he hasn't
really been able to use his powers yet
but now with his mom in danger his eyes
light up and whoa totally wrecked
stormfront but tragically his mom was
standing too close she's hit too it's
like billy it's not his fault you gotta
promise me you'll help raise him right
so he'll be a good guy and butcher's
wife who he thought was dead and
dedicated his life to avenging now dies
for real in his arms now homelander
shows up and is sad to lose his nazi
girlfriend at least he still has his son
but his son's choosing butcher there's
no one to stop him this time
homelander's gonna kill him but queen
maeve comes to save him again but not
with a super fight with their even
stronger weapon blackmail yeah there was
a whole thing with queen maeve's
ex-girlfriend and when homelander found
out he outed her on live tv just to mess
with her and force her into the public
relationship she never wanted and it's
like look you're gonna stop messing with
me or i release it and i guess while i'm
here i'll make not killing butcher part
of the deal too and so homelander whose
reputation is more important to him than
anything else lets his son go so the day
is saved well kind of nazi stormfront is
stopped and compound b is put on hold
but thought still evades any real
consequences maven starlight's still
part of the seven in a nice little
stalemate with homelander and
homelanders back to his good guy persona
although it seems like he's starting to
crack his son goes off with the cia
hopefully to be raised right away from
bot and hollander and they're
reinstating mallory with the boys as an
official off the books taken down
superhero team and their names are
cleared they can go home to their
families hughie and annie get to date
again openly by the way frenchie and
kimiko have their romance going too
there's good news for a train he's back
on the seven but they can't take both of
them so the deep is still a loser but
then as cult leaders talking to
congresswoman newman he opens a fresca
and boom his head explodes
turns out the head exploder soup is
congresswoman newman herself what game
is she playing we'll find out because
our boy huey has just started working
for her and that's where the boys season
2 comes to an end if you like this recap
hit that subscribe button for more of
the best recaps of tv and movies
[Music]